The real life exploits of Liana does
have spotter and his 300 warriors at
Thermopylae have given rise to the
myth of the spot and superhero.
These supremely disciplines,
man of few words who had a body of steel.
It could endure any hardship and
would fight to his last breath.
It's not Japan really did exist
and chief among them was Leon Idus,
the spartan king who defined the moat of
Persia, saving grease from an isolation.
And this week's biographics,
we discovered the real life Leon at us
Leona.
This was born around 540 BCE and the Greek
city of Sparta at that time at Greece
was made up of hundreds of city states
of which Athens and Sparta with the
largest Leona does his father,
Alexandra Idis was the king
of Sparta for the Greeks,
warfare was fie su-preme
statements of a citizen.
This is what made a man a man and gave
him his right to be a part of his city.
Every Greek in every city.
State was obliged to military service
from the age of 20 until the age of 45 in
order to prepare for that life,
boys were put into a military training
camp known as the [inaudible] from the
age of seven. There was only one exception
to this compulsory military service,
the firstborn son of the
king of each city state.
His upbringing would be focused on
grooming him for the power that he would
inherit on his father's
death, Leon. It is. However,
it was the third son of Alexandra Eddie's
his older half brother, kilometers.
The first was first in line to be
the next king of Sparta. As a result,
Liana just spent his formative years
learning how to be a spartan warrior
between the age of seven
and the age of 12 Liana,
this underwent a training regimen along
with a group of other boys under the
supervision of a warden who was
called the page and numerous.
The literal translation
of this is herder of boys.
This was a highly respected spot and
drawn from the highest social class.
Here's all authority, allows him to punish
anyone who misbehaved and to this end,
he was accompanied by a whip wielding
squad of you this who were ready to meet
out as punishments as the system was
designed to produce effective warriors,
great emphasis was placed on
a rough and tumble lifestyle.
The boys were divided into bands and they
chose as their leader the best fighter.
Meanwhile, the predominance would
keep a close eye on their antics,
meeting out punishment to anyone who got
out of line as well as in boy is in the
aggregate. We're not permitted to wear
shoes. It was believed that leaping,
jumping, and running were accomplished
more swiftly and barefoot.
The boys were also allowed just
one cloak throughout the year.
This was designed to force
them to grow accustomed.
Steve Sweltering Summers and freezing
winters making do with what little
covering they had.
Food for the boys was strictly rations
on the belief that a lean hungry man
fights. It's far more effectively
than a fat satiated one.
Also being able to go a long time without
food, which make for a better prepared.
Fifth's was also severely punished
unless it involved the stealing of food.
The logic behind this was that
by at lending to pilfer food,
the boys would be practicing the skills
of foraging that would be needed when on
a military campaign as well as
that training to become Boreus.
The bodies were also taught
to read and to write. In fact,
the Spartans gained a reputation as men
of learning who love to music, poetry,
and dance.
The age of 12 was an important watershed
year in the life of a young spartan.
He was now placed in a band of about a
dozen of his peers in order to live under
the headship of one drawn from his ranks.
This was the Aaron or prefect.
The one chosen was the smartest,
the most battle ready and cunning.
Though there is no record that
Liana just was put in this position,
it is quite likely that he being the son
of the king and it's given the future
battle prowess that he displayed did
indeed serve as an Erin during his teen
years. The other boys had to give
the absolute obedience to him.
They were to act as his servants
collecting firewood and it's fettering
vegetables using their thieving skills.
Also at the age of 12 spartan boys were
taken under the wing of an Erastus or
admirer to receive a form of mentoring
whereas another Grecian city states this
relationship was a sexual one.
This was not the case in spotter desire
for the body rather than the soul of a
boy who was considered to
be the height of shame.
At the age of 18 the Spartan
youth became a malaria, a title,
which means he is nearly an errand.
His military training was now stepped
up cause he came close to entering
military service.
And so already by the age of 20
spots in society has molded me,
honored us into an agile battle ready
military machine full of self confidence,
discipline.
And to killer instincts.
He was ready to make his
mark on the field of battle.
Leon Anders had trained to
be a hoplite warrior. Cop.
Lights were experts in using the short
iron sword and round shield and spear.
They fought in a tight phalynx formation
in which they would approach the enemy
with the shield overhead to form a
tortoise like shell in order to defend
themselves from oncoming arrows.
Just as Liana just was a bouncy,
went to military service, news reached
him that his father, the king had died.
His brother therefore
inherited the throne.
So while one brother took on the mantle
of supreme ruler over the city state,
the other inherited the role that
he had been given his entire life.
That of a spartan warrior.
The Spartan army was divided into age
groups spanning 10 years within these
divisions, and the basic grouping of men
was into mass groups of about 15 men.
It was with these men that Liana does
lived during his twenties it was also
around this time that Liana does married
the daughter of his half brother.
She was named Gorgo and was, by
all accounts, a beautiful lens,
politically astute woman.
After a few years,
they had a son who they
named Cleon Veritas.
My 490 BC, things were not going well
fully on a distance older half brother.
Over the last three years,
Grecian city had one by one
succumbs to the invading Persians.
The capitulation of these powers was a
source of outer to the proud spot and
king, and in 491 the SMT do
overthrow a neighboring king.
It was about two conceit to the Persians,
but when they're kings blands do Alster
duly appointed fellow king were revealed
the people of Sparta.
We're not happy and it's clear.
Manez was forced to flee the city.
He then set about gathering a formidable
army and the surrounding territories
wisely.
The Spartans allows him to return,
but believing that the king had gone
insane, hadn't thrown into chains.
Apparently this order was carried out
on the direction of Lialda spill on his
was placed under the gods
of the heloc slave class.
The imprisoned king managed to persuade
one of his capitalist to lend him his
dagger with,
as he apparently committed and appalling
sort of Harry Carey slicing himself
into pieces from his feet with when
Claremont has it taken the throne in 30
years. Previously has half-brother Doris
who was older than Leon [inaudible],
was sense that the throne had passed him
by finding it impossible to remain in
Sparta. You attempted to establish
a colony in Africa when this fails.
He went to Sicily where he ultimately
met an untimely death and so it was that
on the death of clear Mendez
in 1490 in Leon at us,
it was the next in line for the throne
immediately upon ascending to the throne,
Leon and this was thrown into
the heat of conflict for years.
The Persians had been at threatened in
Greece and now the situation was that a
critical point,
swift action was needed ans neon.
It just proved to be the
right man to deliver it.
The goal of the Persians was the
absolute subjugation of Greece.
They already ruled over a number of
Greek cities on the coast of Asia.
The continued existence of other Greek
city states was a beacon of light for
those already in Gulf to by the Persians,
making them dream of independence.
This was simply not acceptable
to the Persian king,
Xerxes to crush old Grecian resistance
succes and gathered together a massive
force consisting of 1,207 warships and
as many as 1.7 million warriors in stark
contrast, the Greeks were badly disunited
of more than 100 city states. So neat.
31 had agreed. Do you stand
and fight against the Persians?
The kings of these 31 states met and
swore an oath to fight the Persians and to
punish any cities that went
over to the Persian side.
Still with the key states of facily
and by ots supporting Persia,
there was no active resistance to the
invaders right down to the city of Athens.
The Spartans had taken on the mantle
of leadership and the resistance.
The city was recognized as
being in a position of moral,
political and above all
military preeminence in all
of Greece. Under the Oneidas.
The Spartans were absolutely determined
to fight in order to conquer or die the
alliance with other resisting city state
so loudly on it as to put around 60,000
men into the fields getting sacked sees
of Persia believed that his overwhelming
superiority in numbers
would guarantee the victory.
It was his strategy to keep his naval
fleet and does infantry closely connected.
The infantry thus marched along the shore
and so the Persians even dug a canal
through Mount Athos do allow
the ships to stay close.
When the army got inland's by August the
18th 480 Xerxes had overrun Macedonia.
Vaseline is army now.
It arrived at the place they called
Thermopylae and narrow pass between facily
and the ocean,
and the auditors knew that he could
never defeat the entire Persian army,
but he believed that if he could inflicts
a devastating blow of such magnitude
that it decimated a portion of that army.
The psychological damage would be such
that the Persians would withdraw that not
everyone was convinced that this strategy
would actually work. Not Undermining.
The honor does a strategy was
the article of Apollo at Delphi.
This was a person who was considered
to have a hotline to the gods of Greece
when the Spartans had approached the
article asking whether they should resist
the Persians there apply that came
back was either the king of Sparta,
ms die or the Spartans themselves must
be conquered for nothing can stands
before the mice of the Persian king.
Each successive city states that approach.
The article was likewise
given a premonition of
doom. Still they honored us,
was not deterred.
He ends every Spartan Warrior with him
would give his last breath to keep the
Persians out of their beloved
city state they wanted us to do,
wants to meet the overwhelming
Persian force on the open fields.
It was his intention to withdraw to the
spot where the Peloponnesian Peninsula
joins the lance of Attica.
This was a very narrow strip of land,
just a mile and a half long.
Here.
He would set his men to
building a defensive wall
behinds which they would find
sexy says Ami.
The bowling with his plan was that
it left Athens completely without any
protection. So against his
better judgments, neon adjusts,
agreed to take a small force up to
Thermopylae and engage the Persians at the
narrowest point of the past. Here,
the great advantage of the Persians,
the use of cavalry would be negated.
All know,
just decided that 300 Spartan warriors
would be selected for the defense if the
modeling and they would be led by
he himself. So the question is now,
why would just 300 chosen
and why particularly these
301st 300 was a manageable
number for an elite task force.
Secondly,
the figure 300 had a strong symbolic and
it's practical overtone in Sparta as it
was the fixed number of
the regular royal body art.
The body guards were known as cavalry men,
though they in fact served as infantry
men in the dead center of a hoplite
Phalynx. This was where the
commanding king would be stations.
The three injured cavalry
men were especially selected
in an intense competition.
They were selected from the men in the
10 youngest adult citizen year classes
age between 20 and 29
Liana just is the moppet.
The advanced guard of 300 however,
was to be selected with one crucial
additional criteria besides being
exceptionally brave skill for them.
Patriotic each of the chosen
few must have a living son.
This would ensure that his son would be
in place to carry on his father's name.
These as within constitutes an elite
within an elite bursting with pride to
emulates the feet if they're late fathers.
In addition to the 300
Spartans and he honored us,
stuck around for thousands Peloponnesians
and around a thousands noncombatants
ups.
It is clear for the firm,
obsolete 300 words would be
in effect a suicide squad.
The parts of the firm opoly has a flat
plane in front of us and that was where
the Persians were encamped the pass
through the mountains to the sea.
It was only six feet wide at points at
the points where the past wade into 50
feet.
The Spartans set about repairing and
existing wall and making it a much more
defensible location.
After Xerxes is vast passion and
forces arrived at the past as west,
and then a three or four day delay
occurred before he launched his assault.
In this pre battle pause,
it is reported that Xerxes
sends a message to Leon at us.
He demanded that he handed over his arms.
There's spartan king replied
in just two words, Milan Laba,
which essentially means
come and get them yourself.
It was also during this low before
the storm that the Persian advanced
reconnaissance reported back
to Xerxes the strange behavior.
They saw it among the Spartans rather
than being anxious if the coming attack,
the Greek warriors
appeared supremely at ease.
They busied themselves with bathing,
braiding one another's hair and dancing.
The Persians interpreted this as signs
of fear induced madness until they
traitorous Greek in their midst,
informed the king that the Spartans were
certainly not Matt or the Persian spies
had seen where the actions of pound heroes
preparing themselves for their final
life and death struggle.
So the Persian king first sent in the
meets a force of about two thousands but
these forces proved no
match for the Spartans.
They wore near the helmets and all grieves
and their shields were made of wicker
work in the confined spaces of the past.
They were unable to take advantage
of their superiority in numbers.
When the Medes unleashed a hail of
arrows on the defenders in unison,
the Spartans lifted their shields over,
had to form a defensive
roof over their heads.
The Medes and the troops that followed
them did the best they could under the
judgmental.
I have their king,
but it was not enough and they
suffered heavy losses. In fact,
losses were so great on three occasions
that Zach sees is said to have a laptop
in horror from his specially constructed
throne appalled at the carnage and
Sorta of some of his best men behind
the protection of the refurbished wall.
Liana does his men resisted by fighting
and relates this clever tactic,
maximize the efficiency outpost of
their limited resources and energies.
Liana does salsa managed to pull
off a series of feigned retreats,
followed by a sudden about 10 then a
murderous onslaught on that overconfidence
and distorted Sueess.
Eventually towards the end of daylight,
Xerxes felt that he had no option but
to send in his elite royal bodyguard,
the 10,000 immortals under the
command of he Diana's bus. Once again,
the attack was to no avail and it came
at the cost of serious casualties.
The goal and bloodshed that in Gorge
Dinero Mountain pass was overwhelming.
The piles of quickly
rotting corpses mounted,
the flies swarmed and
the stench was palpable.
The battle raged into a second day
and still is axes was unable to make a
breakthrough by now.
Some 20,000 Persians had fallen to the
Greek resistance and the demoralizing
effect on the remains of the Persian
army was telling why could they not turn
back these few simple rentals.
With his frustration of boiling point,
Xerxes finally received his break,
not through his military superiority,
but by means of a traitor.
Xerxes was approached by a Greek term
coach by the name of the fallacies from
the city of malice.
He was very familiar with the
paths crossing the mountain range.
He told the King of another path through
the mountain that would allow the
Persians do bypass the
Greek defensive position.
The Lte is offered to a squat as many as
10,000 Persian trips through that path
by night and turn the
flank of the Spartans.
This Lawson's knew of the existence
of this alternative route,
but they didn't know that Zach season,
you have assets Zach sees gave this
special missions you members of the royal
guard of immortals and
it's led by our facilities.
They had set out in silence at nightfall,
aided by full moon.
After a had climb through the ANA
on mountain range up to 1000 meters.
They easily brushed off and bypass the
thousand fish and guards posted by the
[inaudible].
Notice these troops were ill prepared
and were taken completely by surprise.
We all know just as long been blamed for
not posting a stronger reinforcements
on the anti a path.
By the morning of day three of the
conflicts the Persians had the Greeks out
flanks. We honored us was now when
a pencil grip caught from the rear.
Now as well as the front,
it is at this point that Liana does
having recognized the hopelessness of the
situation,
gathered his forces together and ordered
all of the trips except the Spartans to
make their escape. Their cities
would need them to fight another day,
but the Spartans were to make their
last stand right there at Thermopylae.
All melted away except for a
group of about 400 from Thespis.
When asked by the king
why they too did not go,
they replied that they have stayed
because the Spartans of state,
they would die with them.
The Greeks made their last stands
mostly outside the middle of gate wall.
Liana just showed himself a true spartan
with the order that he gave his men
before the final encounter this
evening we shall die in in hades.
This Barton's sold their
souls that are heavy cost.
The Persian losses at the beginning of
day three were reportedly heavier even
from those sustained on
the previous two days.
The Greeks depleted though their numbers
were repeatedly drove the Persians back
then.
Inevitably,
the 10,000 of the Persian royal guard
of immortals emerged from the rear.
The honor this fought and died like a
man possessed when his sword shattered.
After one too many death blows.
He used his hands and his mouth
to inflict injury upon the enemy.
The exact manner of his
death is on recorded,
but we do know that as soon as he fell,
the Persians took hold of the body and
tried to drag it away. Seeing this,
the Spartans lapse on their king and
attempted to pull him back four times the
on it.
As his body was dragged away before the
remnants of the spot and defenders got
full possession of us and formed
a defensive circle around it.
In this position with that spears and
lances broken their bodies battered and
bloodied and they're dead king,
and that missed the Spartans resulted
to throwing rocks at these surrounding
force of Persians.
Finally,
a massive head of arrows was launched
and the last Spartans were cut down.
Perhaps the greatest testaments do.
The effectiveness of the heroic defense,
which Leon at us had affected against
the Persians was the treatments of his
corpse by so axes, the spartan king was
decapitated and his body was crucified.
So axes then went about trying to hide
the true number of casualties that his
men had suffered.
But the great defense by the Spartans
could not be hidden from history.
The death on honored us and his fellow
Spartans greatly lifted the Greek morale
and the vital period that the Spartans
that held up the Persian advance gave
time for the Athenian Greek fleet to
wreak havoc on the Persian navy and
eventually lead to the
defeat of the Persians.
So by giving his life so dearly
at the [inaudible], the owner,
this became the savior of his people.
So I really hope you enjoyed that
episode of biographics. If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday.
So hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube. If you actually want to
get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time, every Monday
and Thursday when we put out a new video.
Also, if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive over
there on the right and other ways
for watching.